okay six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty our next caller is
from the seven to zero area code go
ahead hi back Ben uh my name's Sean and
I live in Colorado and I think what
we're really dealing with in America and
we're missing the major problem here or
the major point okay is that the
Democratic Party is a party of enablers
they enable the Republican Party to get
away with their evil and even more so
than that even support them in times
like the support of the banks and they
supported uh the deregulation of Wall
Street yep
and was really going on here is that
from the top down the Democrats the
Democratic establishment is considered
leadership and is created this idea that
in order to be a liberal or or to be a
leftist you kind of have to be a coward
you know what I mean that you're not
willing to really fight and what this
does is embolden Republican and allows
stuff like the Supreme Court I mean like
Obama he had the Supreme Court
nomination if he had any sense of
anything he would have been on TV day in
and day out saying the Republicans are
unamerican they are going against the
Constitution day after day after day and
may the Republicans pay for it but he
didn't do that because of the fact he
kind of agrees with Republicans and a
lot of the corporate Democrats do so I
think the real issue is is that people
on the Left need to know it's okay to be
strong you know what I mean it's okay to
be like no no I want health care for
people because the fact I believe that
that is right and even more so like you
can even argue from a Christian angle
like Jesus said feed the poor the hungry
the sick is a needy you will go to
heaven those who don't go to hell like
there's there's like so many arguments
but the Democratic Party pretty much
just enables the Republicans to do
anything they want day after day after
day yep
so listen a bunch of good points in
there couple different things number one
you can hold simultaneously the belief
that you have just disposed Sean which
is that a lot of the actions of the
Democratic establishment are either
supportive of or inadvertently complicit
with maintaining the
worst elements of the status quo
including how politics is financed the
sort of corporate oligarchy that governs
the United States so on and so forth you
can believe that and at the same time
when it comes down to who am i voting
for because there are real differences
on very important issues between
Republicans and Democrats I'm gonna
choose to vote for the Democrat you can
hold both of those beliefs you can also
recognize that although we want to break
the two-party duopoly as I've talked
about doing with campaign finance reform
and ranked choice voting and some of the
other means that we've talked about we
still can work within the Democratic
Party two primary rightist and corporate
Democrats when there are opportunities
to do that without doing more
self-inflicted harm and move the
Democratic Party to the left to the
extent that it's possible and I I can't
I really can't disagree with anything
you've said and I think it's just
important to remember that everything
you said can be true and yet we can
still improve circumstances by voting
for some of the right Democrats when we
have the opportunity to do so yeah and
and III would I wouldn't necessarily
disagree with you I mean personally I'm
just kind of sick of like corporate
Democrats I think I'm gonna vote third
party but if people want to vote
Democratic I'm in complete support of
that I think my major issue is that we
need to have a new understanding of what
it means to be on the left that's
because the the concept of people on the
left is kind of a representation of what
the Democrats are but the donors peak
week Democrats a strong Republican and
the Republicans just emo everything they
want through and people on the Left get
this sense of oh I gotta be like the
Democrats you know what I mean instead
of actually being like no this is an
issue that I'm willing to fight for I'm
stand for and I'm even willing to like
yell about it or you know you know what
I mean it's like we listen we makin
George Lakoff has a ton of writing on
this and he says Democrats and and
actual progressives some of whom are
Democrats and some of whom are not need
to start framing their issues our issue
choose as actually the patriotic thing
to do right hey listen
yeah we are a country that values the
people within it and we're gonna make
sure people have some basic level of
health care we are going to do our
patriotic duty to make sure we have the
best country possible by paying our
taxes not by trying to give tax cuts to
the rich which is not the patriotic
thing to do it's actually the opposite
of patriotism to do that Lake Hoff has a
lot of good good stuff on this and I
wish more people in power on the Left
read read that and maybe took some
lessons out of it okay and I just want
to add one thing and I and and and I
agree with that I just and I agree with
that my major point is I think we need
to be harsher and I think like we need
to say the Republicans are immoral you
know any mean like the biggest problem
with Trump is they don't understand he's
a bully and you can't you don't beat a
bully by saying you're mean you know any
mean you're listen Johnny you say like
people are mad and because I'm saying
some of that you know it might be time
for some tactics to protest what this
administration is doing that are going
to make people uncomfortable and I'm
getting emails from people saying that
my tone is all wrong what about civility
you're just not going to fight back
against what's going on by saying I
respectfully disagree please stop what
you're doing it's just some someone's
gonna have to end up uncomfortable
that's just the reality at this point
absolutely and the reason and I think
the reason that you are getting those
emails is because they're following the
leadership quote-unquote of the
Democratic establishment in so so what
they see is like Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer they're like you know what if
people start getting me more more people
have died in terrorists from right-wing
Republicans in the United States the
Muslim you know alike besides 9/11
obviously but you know like since then
so and so forth and it's just like we
need to be like no this is a moral
situation and if you don't think a poor
child or a single mother deserves health
care or a livable wage
it's like yeah sorry
all right Sean thank you really
appreciate it points well made and keep
keep fighting out there I appreciate
what you're doing